you mentioned it with the spirit did you
feel like their shot making affected
kind of your team especially late in
terms of seeing you know guys drop their
heads seeing those types of things and
do you view that to be a tonight issue
or is that a culmination of the last 13
games I think it's just you know
whenever you play good defense high
level defense and guys are able to knock
down shots especially guys that you know
have coming in coming into the game
hadn't really shot the ball well for the
opposing team or you play Perfect
Defense with 23 seconds that 20 you know
22 seconds that 23rd second the shot
goes up and they hit it and it is what
it is it's the NBA man this is a
marathon and you know you have to look
at the totality of the picture I'm tired
of people living and dying with every
single game we play I'm like it's it's
it's ludicrous actually it's like come
on man this is a marathon and we're
hitting we hit a tough stretch you know
it's the same team that you know we
played some high level games a little
while ago and we just got to get back to
that we got to keep the fight though we
cannot lose our
fight